There are two general situations
in which Mitch mismatch can occur.
One is when there is rapid change
and culture, uh, over time.
And the other is when
humans move in space,
the Miss Masters in time are caused by
the major cultural and epidemiological
transitions that have been occurring.
And there we can see an estimate of
how fast things can happen by studying
lactase persistence because
we have a time point when, uh,
we started dairying culture and that
is when selection began for lactase
persistence in space.
We can study emigration and immigration,
they are moving people between different
kinds of selection regimes and we can
start with the agricultural
and industrial revolutions.
So in the left panel we have a historical
timeline running from the Paleolithic
about 10,000 years ago
up through the present.
In the center panel we have lifestyle.
And over here we have the microorganisms
that were associated with that.
So in the Paleolithic, we were in
small groups of less than a hundred.
And the agricultural revolution was
associated with the first epidemiological
transition.
Prior to the agricultural revolution,
we have worms mycobacteria
a happy gut microbiota.
We had healed helicobacter
pylori, Salmonella Toxoplasma
and lack of facility.
Then in the agricultural revolution,
we started living in the larger social
groups. We domesticated animals,
we had cats and dogs around. There
was increased oral fecal transmission.
At this point,
about 97% of the population was still
living in a rural environment where they
were living on farms, exposed
to animals, feces, mud,
untreated water and so forth.
And that continued up to the 18th,
the 19th century in Europe.
In this period there were
measure microbial changes.
So the more settled lifestyle actually
led to more worms and more oral fecal
transmission.
And there were novel infections
that epidemiology suggests
we're not part of the
Paleolithic community of pathogens.
They include a whole group of viruses,
the Pyrrole,
Mixel viruses and so forth
that are mumps and uh,
things like that.
Measles,
this is where influence of BNC came in.
And also where smallpox,
cholera, plague and typhus appear to have
entered the human population to become
significant diseases.
The next major transition as much more
recent, that's the industrial revolution.
And the associated second
epidemiological transition.
Our lifestyle shifted to being urbanized
where there was a lot more concrete and
tarmac where soap and
detergents became widely used,
food was washed,
there was less oral fecal transmission.
Chlorinated water became available,
there was less contact with animals
and there were antibiotics, vaccines,
deworming, Asians, so we had
fewer worms, less toxoplasma,
less helicobacter,
less Sudoku,
commensals from mud and water analyst,
Very Gut Microbiota.
Now,
much of this mismatch we
currently experience is the
result of these two events,
the agricultural revolution
and the industrial revolution.
So before agriculture,
more worms,
helicobacter salmonella gut
for diverse gut Microbiota,
tuberculosis. We ate fruits,
vegetables, nuts, meat and fish.
With agriculture we picked up
measles, mumps, flew, smallpox,
cholera and typhus.
We domesticated animals,
we drank milk,
we shifted to eating more green.
We were living on farms and had
more oral fecal transmission.
Then with the industrial revolution, came
syrup to toe detergents, antibiotics,
deworming,
less exposure to helmets,
less toxoplasma helicobacter,
Salmonella and less varied gut microbiota.
So with the postindustrial world,
we are more sedentary and
we have more global travel
to interpret the kinds of changes
that go on in these major transitions.
It helps to focus on lactase persistence,
the ability to continue to
digest milk as an adult.
Prior to agriculture,
the ability to digest milk was president
in infants up to about two years of age,
but then disappeared
with the domestication of
dairy animals that made it
advantageous for adults to digest milk.
And we know that daring originated
about three to 9,000 years ago.
So lactase persistence,
the ability of adult adults to digest
milk is hot. Currently not universal.
It's prevalence ranges from about 95 to
97% in Scandinavia to only up to 10% in
East Asia.
Some populations can't do it at all.
So data and theory together suggest that
the selective advantage of digesting
milk as adults has been about oh
0.5% to 3% which is pretty strong.
The 3% selective advantage means that a
person who can digest milk is an adult,
has on average 3% more grandchildren.
Then does
the person who cannot digest milk.
So the message is that evolution takes
hundreds of generations to adjust
populations to new conditions.
It has not yet completed that adjustment
for this important element of our diet.
Now what if immigration,
immigration done to mismatch immigrants
bring with them diseases that the
populations into which they're
moving have not yet experienced?
They also leave some pathogens and
symbiotes behind them. When they move,
they switched to new diets and lifestyles
and all three effects results in
mismatches that have health consequences.
Here is what happened when
Europeans brought small pox
into populations that had
never experienced smallpox.
There were huge epidemics.
So in Hispaniola between 1507 and 1518
up to 300,000 people died in Mexico in
just one year,
1520 to 1521 between two and 15 million
people died in Peru between 1525 and
1527 at least 200,000 died in Brazil
between 1550 and 18 1880 about 3 million
died and so forth.
So when smallpox entered the new world,
it caused enormous epidemics.
There are other effects that pathogens
can be left behind. So for example,
when the slave trade brought
African Americans to the new world,
they left malaria behind an Africa,
but they retained the costs
of sickle cell disease.
Immigrants today to develop countries
suffer more allergies and asthma than do
locals.
They are leaving their microbiota behind
and they're moving into a more hygienic
environment. They also switched
to new diets and lifestyles.
So when Japanese immigrants came to Hawaii
about 1890 to 1910 they switched from
a diet high in fish, rice and tea
to a diet that had more red meat,
animal fat and milk
men of Japanese ethnicity in Hawaii.
We're then twice as likely to die of
heart disease is those who lived in Japan
and the children of Japanese immigrants
were about 10 centimeters taller than
their parents as a result of the milk
and animal fat in their diet when they
were growing up.
So to summarize,
mismatchers can occur
in both time and space.
The agriculture and industrial revolution
produced major shifts in lifestyle and
in Diet.
And an exposure to microorganisms in our
biology has not yet had time to catch
up with them.
We experience serious health consequences
from the agricultural revolution,
so the domestication of living in
cities brought with it. Things like flu,
measles, smallpox, cholera,
and typhus that Paleolithic Hunter
gatherers did not normally encounter
with the industrial revolution.
The consequences include obesity,
type two diabetes, osteoporosis, colon
cancer, and cardiovascular disease,
as well as some of the benefits such as
lower infant mortality and longer life,
which are both reasons that we are now
exposed to some of these chronic diseases.
Immigrant's experience changes
in Diet and in Microbiota.
They can actually dramatically change the
prevalence of noncommunicable diseases
and immigrant populations,
so they have more asthma and allergy.